here is CNN's Dana Bash with ever
insightful information on the Trump
arrest
turns out even Jack Smith can't resist a
five dollar footlong
to what we see right there new and
exclusive CNN video of the special
council at Subway declining though to
respond to reporters questions about
today's big news a Target letter sent to
the former president of the United
States CNN's Evan Perez was there trying
to track down the special counsel I
won't ask you all of the uh less
important things about what he got and
yeah how he paid and all that but but
what is important is the imagery here
they clearly wanted us to see him uh and
and that image to be very different from
what we saw in the president former
president's post with which is that he's
a a deranged individual
we're going to mostly focus on the
sandwich and what this guy ate six inch
foot long did he get lettuce how much
mustard did he have on and also he's
deranged by the way you know the guy is
completely completely the way they frame
and by the that was exclusive video of
CNN my God that's incredible CNN had a
man standing outside a Subway holy sheep
but it continued it wasn't just
Dana Bash I'm fairly certain this is her
husband can you Google this real quick
is Dana Bash married to John King I'm 99
sure the answer is yes they're gonna
google it while we show you John King
also also analyzing what Jack Smith had
for lunch
and just one last point
Jack Smith remember when the classified
documents Target letter when Trump
announced that there's a lot of
commentary it was Jack Smith making a
mistake here is he leaving this all to
Donald Trump and then they release the
indictment and we all said wow wow we
read it we saw the documentation we saw
the level of detail Jack Smith going to
Subway today is a message to Donald
Trump Donald Trump tries to intimidate
people he tries to bully people he tries
to scare you away that was Jack Smith
with no words and a simple five dollar
Sub in his hand saying I'm here I'm not
going to yeah the imagery was uh was
intentional and spoke volumes it really
is all right first off we did a little
Googling
apparently Dana Bash and John King were
married they are now divorced let's just
put that aside it's funny that they're
still working together on CNN is what it
is uh that is some of the dumbest
analysis I have ever heard in my entire
life he honestly believes and they sit
there and they agree with him that
somehow Jack Smith having lunch I mean
the guy just decided to go for lunch
that that was to send a message to
Donald Trump like you see I'm so calm
and cool and collected about this
indictment that I can get a five dollar
six inch Subway sandwich okay that is
and they they look at him as if that is
a sensible thing to say that is any
bearing to do with reality now I
actually do believe it might be
coordinated because why was CNN standing
outside the very Subway that the guy was
going into are they are they tracking
him all day like is CNN tracking the
prosecutor all day long to follow him I
mean that seems a little weird but uh
that really sent him he would have sent
a message to Donald Trump if he would
have gone to Orange Julius in the mall
and been sucking down one of those gross
orange things like sea orange man I got
you and I'm gonna suck you dry that
would have been something by going to
Subway all he's proving is that he
wasn't near a Jersey Mike's because
Jersey Mike's is obviously way better
than Subway everyone knows that
[Music]
thank you